The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on non-linear finite
element analysis.
In the previous lectures, I
introduced you to non-linear
finite element analysis, to
the solution methods that
we're using in non-linear finite
element analysis, using
primarily physical concepts.
We are now ready to discuss the
mathematical basis of the
procedures that we're using
to obtain solutions.
Of course, this material is very
complex, and there is a
lot we could discuss.
But let us have a go at it.
We have a body that undergoes
large displacements, large
rotations, and large strains.
So therefore, we consider
the body to
undergo very large motions.
We will use a Lagrangian
description of the
motion of the body.
Here, on this viewgraph, I have
prepared schematically
the body that we
are looking at.
Here the body is in its
configuration at time zero.
Notice that the area is, the
surface area of the body is
described as 0 A, the volume
is described as 0 V, the 0
being a left superscript.
I should point out, at this
point, that you will be
encountering now a lot of
superscripts and subscripts,
and that actually makes the
discussion somewhat difficult.
And for that reason, I like to
take now, on this viewgraph,
just a minute to explain to you
why we have a particular
superscript, a particular
subscript, in that particular
location, and what
it means to us.
So, a left superscript here, as
shown on A and V, means at
time indicated by that, at the
time indicated by that
superscript.
So here we have 0 A, 0 V once
again, area at time 0,
volume at time 0.
A particular point here, point
P, has the coordinates 0 X 1,
0 X 2, 0 X 3.
Now, notice that these upper
0s here correspond to the
time, as I just pointed out,
whereas 1, 2, and 3, of
course, correspond to
the coordinate axis.
This is a particular
material particle.
This material particle will move
with the body from time 0
to time t as shown on
this viewgraph.
Of course, at this particular
time now, the surface area of
the body has become t A,
t now meaning surface
area at time t.
And the volume of the body
is t V. Notice that the
coordinates of this material
particle now are t x
1, t x 2, t x 3.
We will assume, later on in our
actual solution, that the
solution up to time t is known,
in other words, that
the area, the volume, in fact,
the stresses, the strains, at
time t are known.
And that we will want to march
ahead one time increment, to
time, t plus delta t.
Notice the volume of the body,
now, is given by t plus delta
t V. The surface area is given
by t plus delta t A. The
coordinates of the material
particle have now become t
plus delta t x 1, t plus delta t
x 2, and t plus delta t x 3.
Well, there's one very
important point.
And that important point is that
we are considering that
the Cartesian coordinate axis
in which the motion of the
body is measured remains
stationary.
You should always keep
that in mind.
In other words, here we have the
Cartesian axis, x 1, x 2,
x 3, and those remain
stationary, whereas the body
moves through those axes,
through the, well, system of
axes, And we want to, of course,
solve for that motion.
With the particle motion
described by the coordinates
that I just mentioned, we can
now define the following
quantities down here.
We can say that t x i, the
coordinates at time t of the
material particle, are
equal to 0 x i--
both of those quantities, of
course, we know already now
what they are--
plus t u i.
t u i are just the displacements
from
time 0 to time t.
Similarly for the situation
from time 0 to time
t plus delta t.
Notice that these are now the
displacements from time 0 to
time t plus delta t.
And we can, of course, talk
also about the incremental
displacements.
The incremental displacements
from time t plus delta t, or
rather from time t, I should
say, to time t plus delta t.
And those incremental
displacements
are given by u i.
Of course, the lower right
subscript always
refers to the axis.
In other words, i goes from
one to two to three.
For the u's and for the x's.
Well, I mentioned already that
the Cartesian axes are
stationary.
And I have prepared this
viewgraph to point it out once
more very strongly.
The unit distances along the
xi-axis are the same for 0 x
i, t x i, and t plus
delta t x i.
That is also a very
important point.
Let's look at this very
simple example.
Here we have an x 2- axis,
and we have the x
1-axis along here.
Notice the units along this axis
are 1, 2, 3, and so on.
The material particle
has initially the
coordinates, 2, say.
Of course, then, this being
the length of 0 x 1.
This particle, at time 0, moves
to time t by t u 1, the
way we just said it earlier.
And of course, the sum of
these two quantities is
equal to t x 1.
Notice that t x 1 is measured
along the same axis, with the
same unit distances, as 0 x 1.
And therefore, for this reason,
we now use just x 1
here, without the left
superscript, to denote the
coordinate axis.
By the way, in my book, the
textbook for this video
course, I have frequently
put here, a t or 0.
I feel now, it is better,
actually, to drop that
superscript, because this
description, the way I just
explained it to you, I think,
is even better.
Well, let us talk now,
then, about the
principle of virtual work.
And now, we want to look at the
principle of virtual work
applied to time t
plus delta t.
The reason being, of course,
that we want to solve for the
static and kinematic variables
at time t plus delta t.
We assume that we know
the solution from
time 0 to time t.
We discussed in the previous
lectures already the principle.
I'd like to now just review it
once more, because it's just
of utmost importance to very
well grasp, understand what
the principle says, and
how we apply it then.
Here we have now the
Cauchy stresses.
I defined the Cauchy stresses
earlier as the
force per unit area.
The i j, of course, mean
coordinate axis, i and j.
In three dimensional analysis,
going from 1 to 3.
t plus delta t means the
Cauchy stress at time
t plus delta t.
These are the real stresses
that we want to solve for.
Here we have virtual strains.
These are infinitesimally small
strains, referred to the
configuration at time
t plus delta t.
This t plus delta t means a
reference to the configuration
at time t plus delta t.
And here we have, of course,
the t plus delta t d V,
because we're integrating over
that volume which, of course,
is unknown in the incremental
solution.
This is the internet virtual
work, which must be equal to
the external virtual work.
Here is again, the script R. And
this script R, at time t
plus delta t, is defined down
here in the viewgraph.
We're integrating over the
volume, at time t plus delta
t, the body forces.
And these are the real body
forces, of forces per unit
volume at time t plus delta t,
multiplied by the virtual
displacements, delta u i.
And the integration, of course,
goes over the volume
at time t plus delta t.
We're adding to this part the
surface forces, forces per
unit area, at time t plus delta
t, multiplied by the
virtual displacements
on the surface.
This capital S stands for "on
the surface." And this product
is integrated over the total
surface of the body at time t
plus delta t.
We assume that we know this part
once we have imposed a
virtual displacement.
And therefore, we can calculate
the right-hand side.
Corresponding to that virtual
displacement we
obtain virtual strains.
And therefore, we can
calculate also
the left-hand side.
And once again, the principle of
virtual work says, that the
left-hand side, the internal
virtual work, must be equal to
the right-hand side, the
external virtual work, for any
arbitrary virtual displacements
that satisfy the
displacement boundary
conditions.
Of course, remember, as I
pointed out earlier, in an
earlier lecture, that the
virtual strains must
correspond to the virtual
displacements.
And here we have the virtual
strains, once again.
On the viewgraph we saw this
stress, and I call it the
Cauchy stress.
Here, you have it spelled
out once more.
It's the force per unit area
at time t plus delta t.
We also talked about the
virtual strains.
And the virtual strains here,
this was the quantity R,
defined as shown on the
right-hand side.
Let me once again point strongly
out that we are
differentiating here, with
respect to the coordinates, at
time t plus delta t.
Of course, the j and
the i coordinate.
And also, please recognize that
this strain is really the
infinitesimal strain tensor
that you are very well
familiar with in infinitesimal
analysis, in infinitesimal
displacement analysis, I should
say, except for one
difference that we're using
here, the unknown coordinates
at time t plus delta t.
And that is spelled out down
here, that we are using a
variation in the small strains
referred to the configuration,
at time t plus delta t.
So really, if you are familiar
with the principle of virtual
work, as applied in
infinitesimal displacement
analysis, then you recognize
that the principle of virtual
work now applied to large
deformation analysis, large
displacement analysis, is quite
the same, except that we
are applying it to the current
geometry, the current
configuration of the body.
In my textbook, actually, I have
a little note, a footnote
that you might also look at,
in the beginning of Chapter
Six, where I discuss this
principle of virtual work,
that one way to look at it is
that you see a body and, you
see the body in front of
yourself moving through the
stationary coordinate frame--
once again, the Cartesian
coordinate frame is
stationary.
You see it move, you see the
body move through that
coordinate frame.
And there is somebody standing,
taking a picture.
And that picture is taken
at time t plus delta t.
And now you have a picture.
And you apply the principle
of virtual work to that
particular configuration
which has been
captured in that picture.
That's perhaps one way to look
at it, at least one way that I
like to look at it.
In order to solve, or to work
with the principal of virtual
work, you need to rewrite the
principal, really, because we
cannot integrate over an unknown
volume, and we cannot
directly work with increments
in the Cauchy stresses.
The volume t plus delta t,
remember, is unknown.
And the reason why we cannot
directly work, or simply work
with increments in Cauchy
stresses is because a Cauchy
stress is always referred to the
current geometry, current
configuration.
So if we talk about the Cauchy
stress at time t, then it's
the force per unit
area at time t.
And the Cauchy stress at time
t plus delta t is the force
per unit area at time
t plus delta t.
Now you can't add a quantity
that is referred to time t to
a quality that is referred to
time t plus delta t, because
the areas, the reference
areas, have changed.
And we have to somehow take
care of that in our
formulation.
And for that reason, we
introduce these two new
quantities.
The t 0 s is the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
And the t 0 epsilon is the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor.
We introduce these quantities
because these are well known
quantities.
If you were to look into
continuum mechanics texts,
they have been described
in many, many books.
And they are well known
for some time.
But we have extracted,
basically, this information
from the continuum mechanics
literature, because it's a
convenient, these are convenient
stress and strain
measures to work with in
large deformation,
finite element analysis.
So, this is the stress
and that is the
strain we will be using.
And let me say the
following now.
This t here, the upper t, means
stress at time t, in the
configuration at time t.
This lower 0 means that the
stress is referred to the
configuration at time 0.
Similarly for the Green-Lagrange
strain.
Upper left, the configuration in
which the strain, or stress
measure is measured, and the
lower subscript means, to
which the configuration,
to which the
measure is referred to.
So this is something to keep
in mind, because we will be
encountering this quite a bit.
Here is the definition of the
stress tensor, t 0 s i j.
Once again, the stress in
configuration t, referred to
the configuration at time 0.
i j, of course, being the
Cartesian coordinate
components.
Here we have the mass
density ratio.
The mass density at time 0, in
configuration 0, if you like.
The mass density at time t, in
configuration at time t.
And here we have a new quantity,
which is actually
the inverse of the deformation
gradient.
This is a component
of the inverse of
the deformation gradient.
We will talk about this quantity
quite a bit just now.
Here we have the
Cauchy stress.
And here we have another
component such as that one.
This is the 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stress.
Once again, I will talk about
this piece of information
quite a bit just now.
The Green-Lagrange strain tensor
is defined as shown
here, t 0 epsilon i j, i j, of
course, being the components
into the Cartesian coordinate
axes, 1/2 t 0 u i comma j plus
t zero u j comma i plus t 0 u k
comma i times t zero u k j.
Notice that here we would select
a particular i and j,
say i equals 1, j equals 2.
You would substitute those i and
j numbers in here, so to
say, and here as well.
And notice that this k then,
would actually run over all
possibilities.
k going from 1, then
to 2, then to 3.
In other words, there is a
summation involved here.
By the way, similarly, we have
a summation involved here,
because m and n would run over
all the possibilities.
I will talk just now a little
bit more about it.
But let's first now look at how
this particular piece of
information here is defined.
It's defined as a partial of 0
x i with respect to t x m.
Notice that this coordinate,
of course, is given, is
assumed to be given.
And that one here is also
now assumed to be given.
Notice, of course, that t x
m is equal to 0 x m plus a
displacement that
has occurred.
Notice that this differentiation
here is
defined as given here, partial
t u i with respect to the
original coordinates.
So, this lower 0 here, this
lower 0 here refers to the
fact that we're differentiating
with respect
to the original coordinates.
This upper t here means that
we are differentiating the
displacement at time t.
Notice, of course, that i and
j are dummy indices here.
So, in fact, this one here
is what I'm considering.
But at the same time, I'm
considering that one, if I
just switch around i and j.
So these are the definitions
of these two quantities.
And I mentioned briefly already
that we are summing in
these definitions.
For example, t s 1 1 would be
calculated from the formulas
that I gave you as 0
rho over t rho--
this, of course, is a scalar--
times this product here.
What do we do here?
We are selecting the
1 as that 1 here.
That 1 here refers to that 1.
And then we are letting these
components here, these
components here, and that one
here, run over all the
possibilities.
Notice, here we have 1 2.
That is this 1 here,
and that 1, 2.
And here we have
3, 3 3, and 3.
So in other words, these
first two are fixed.
These first two here are fixed,
this 1 and that 1.
They correspond to this
1, to these two 1s.
But the other components vary
over all the possibilities,
namely, 1, to 2, to 3.
This is here the summation
convention, which is
abundantly used in continuum
mechanics.
And you might be very well
familiar with it.
Using this 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stress and Green-Lagrange
strain tensors--
and that is really the important
point now-- we can
rewrite the basic equation of
the principle of virtual work
in the form given here.
Here on the left-hand side, we
have the Cauchy stresses times
the variations on the
infinitesimal strains, or the
small, infinitesimally virtual
small strains.
We integrate this product
over the current volume.
And we mentioned already that
we cannot deal with this
integration very well.
Well, we now rewrite, we can
rewrite this integral as shown
here, 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stresses times variations in
the Green-Lagrange strains.
And we integrate this, we are
integrating this product over
the original volume
of the body.
And that is the clue.
We know this volume.
We asked in general,
increment analysis.
We would not know this volume
if, for example, we only have
calculated the response
up to t minus delta t.
So, if we know this volume we
can directly deal with this
integration.
And we will see also that since
these stress components
are always referred to the same
volume, the same area, we
can also incrementally decompose
these stresses.
And the same holds
for the strains.
Notice this relation, of course,
holds for all times,
delta t, 2 delta t,
t, t plus delta t.
The way we talked about the
principal of virtual work just
now, we really had, on the
left-hand side here,
t plus delta t.
Well, you would just exchange
this t, that t, and that t,
and that t here, to
a t plus delta t.
And similarly, of course, on the
right-hand side as well.
I chose at the preparation of
the viewgraph to simply call
it t, because after all, this
equation holds anyways, for
any of those particular times.
To develop, then, the
incremental finite element
equations, we use the
principle of virtual
work in this form.
If we assume that at, that the
response has been calculated
from time 0 to time t, we apply
the principle of virtual
work at time t plus delta t.
We integrate, now, over
a known volume,
as I pointed out.
And, we can directly decompose
the stresses at time t plus
delta t, and the Green-Lagrange
strains at time
t plus delta t as shown
in these equations.
Now, notice that here we have
the stress at time t plus
delta t referred to the
configuration at time 0 being
equal to the stress at time t
referred to the configuration
at time 0 plus an incremental
that is also
referred to time 0.
And this is what we
would like to see.
Similarly for the Green-Lagrange
strain.
These two items make if for us
possible to work very well
with the principle of virtual
work in this particular form.
Before developing, however,
the incremental continuum
mechanics equations, I'd like
to discuss with you now some
important kinematic
relationships that we use in
general non-linear analysis.
The 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff stress
and Green-Lagrange strains
have some very interesting,
properties that I think I'd
like to share with you
in a discussion.
To explain some of these
properties, we want to
introduce the deformation
gradient tensor.
The deformation gradient tensor
is actually something
very, very basic in continuum
mechanics.
And so, let us spend a little
bit of time on this tensor, to
get also a bit of a physical
feel for what it means, what
it stands for, and what
can we do with it.
The tensor captures the
straining of the body and the
rotation of the body.
And, as I mentioned, it is
really a very fundamental
quantity used in continuum
mechanics.
The definition of
the deformation
gradient is as follows.
Here, we have t 0 x being equal
to a matrix, a large
matrix, which, of course, is
written in a Cartesian
coordinate system.
And notice what we're doing in
the elements of that matrix.
We take the partial of t x
1 with respect to 0 x 1.
In other words, we're taking the
coordinates at time t and
differentiate them with respect
to the original
coordinates.
Here, the 1 component with
respect to the 1 component.
Here, the t x 1 with respect
to the 0 x 2.
And, t x 1 with respect
to 0 x 3.
Like that, we get a three
by three matrix.
Using indicial notation, we can
simply say that an element
of that matrix, t 0 X i j,
capital X, because the matrix
is defined as the capital t 0 X,
being equal partial of t X
i with respect to 0 x j.
Of course, i j are
those i j's here.
And, you will also find in the
textbook the following
notation here, t 0 x i j.
Notice, when I have a comma
here, we denote the
differentiation by that comma,
and we use a little x.
That is different from using
the capital X here, with no
comma, because that capital X
simply denotes a component of,
let's go up here once more,
the t 0 x of that matrix.
So this is a mathematical
definition, really, of the
deformation gradient.
And notice that in order to
calculate the elements of this
matrix, of course what you need
to be given is this t x
1, t x 2, t x 3, as a function
of 0 x 1, 0 x 2, and 0 x 3.
If you are given the deformation
field, t x i as a
function of the 0 x j's, then
you can calculate directly the
components of the three
by three matrix.
Another way to write the
deformation gradient is via
this equation.
t 0 x can be written
as 0 del, del 0.
This here is a gradient
operator.
Let's look down here.
We have defined it here.
Times t x, or this gradient
operator operates, I should
say, on t x capital T. This
capital T means transposed.
And this t x capital T
is given right here.
Notice what we're listing in
this vector here now, in this
row vector, are simply the
coordinates at time t, t x 1,
t x 2, t x 3.
Notice that there is
a transpose here.
That transpose is simply
introduced to make sure that
this right-hand side is equal to
what we have defined on the
previous viewgraph this to be.
If you leave out that capital
T, you would not quite get
what we actually have defined
on the previous viewgraph.
So that's why we put that
capital T in there.
It would be a nice exercise
for you to just actually
substitute from here into there,
plug into there, and
write out the three by three
matrix, to make sure that you
actually get what's given here
on the left-hand side the way
we defined it on the
previous viewgraph.
The deformation gradient, as I
briefly mentioned, describes
the deformations, the rotations,
and stretches of
the material fibers.
Let's look at some
examples now.
For example, if we have d 0 x
here, that is the material
fiber in its original
configuration.
Of course, that original
configuration is going to be
deformed, moved through the
stationary coordinate system.
That fiber moves into
this situation here.
It becomes d t x.
The deformation gradient gives
us this element as a function
of that element, as given
in this equation.
In other words, d t x is equal
to t 0 x times d 0 x.
If you know this piece of
information, and you have
calculated the deformation
gradient, you
directly get d t x.
That's what the deformation
gradient does for us.
Well, an example.
It's always nice to look at some
examples to demonstrate
what we mean by these
theoretical formulas.
And here we have a very
simple example.
It's a one dimensional
deformation.
We start off with this piece
of material, a rectangular
piece of material.
And that piece of material is
stretched out from time 0 to
time t into this red
configuration.
Quite a bit of stretching, but
the motion is simple because
it's a uni-axial motion.
Notice, the original length of
this piece of material is 1,
and this side here
moves out 0.5.
Of course, the material
particles here will move.
For example, a particle that was
originally here, the black
little lines there, will move
over to the right, and it
becomes this red little line.
This black line moves over
to become that red line.
Notice the displacement of this
black line is given by
this blue arrow here.
This black line moves over to
there, and the displacement is
given by that blue arrow.
If we know the displacements of
all these particles here,
we know the deformation field.
Vice versa, if the deformation
field is given, and now we
look at this equation here, we
know the displacements of all
of the particles along.
And t x 1 is equal to 0 x
1 for this particular
deformation field plus
0.5 0 x 1 squared.
Let's look at what this means.
It tells that if I plug in a
particular coordinate on the
right-hand side of a material
particle in its original
configuration, then I'm going to
get the final coordinate of
that same material particle,
that same material particle.
Well, the deformation gradient
is defined via this
relationship, and it's
therefore given
as 1 plus 0 x 1.
Notice, we have only motion in
one direction, so we only
calculate this one component.
Let's consider, quite
physically, a material
particle initially at
x 1 equals 0.8.
In other words, x 1 is
this direction, 0 x
1 is equal to 0.8.
Remember, x 1 just gives us
the coordinate direction.
We now put a 0 on it to signify
that 0.8 is the
position of the particle
initially.
That particle moves with the
deformation field that I've
been given to this point here,
and t x 1 is then 1.120.
The same can, of course, be
repeated for an adjacent
material particle.
In other words, let us look
now at a material particle
that is just a little bit to the
right-hand side, namely 0
x 1 being 0.850, slightly to
the right-hand side of the
other material particle
that we looked at.
This material particle, with the
deformation field that we
have been prescribing, moves
to t x 1, this number here.
We can now compute t 0 x 1 1,
the element of the deformation
gradient as this difference
here.
And the numbers are
plugged in here.
And we obtain 1.82.
Of course this is an estimate,
because we did not take a
differential.
If we actually calculate the
deformation gradient the way
it's being defined, we get 1.80,
which is quite close to
the estimate here.
The reason for that difference,
of course, is that
0 x 1, for this particle, is not
close enough, close enough
to the earlier particle,
the other particle that
we also looked at.
In other words, 0.850 is not
close enough to 0.8, in order
to get a very close relationship
here between
these two numbers.
Let's look at another
example, a two
dimensional deformation example.
Here now, we have as the
original configuration, this
black body here, black outline
shown, in the coordinate
system x 1 X 2.
Once again, remember the
coordinate system is
stationary.
And let us look at two
material fibers, this
one and that one.
This one does not carry a hat.
That one carries a hat.
So these are two different
material fibers.
These fibers move to here
from time 0 to time t.
This fiber, d 0 x
becomes d t x.
That fiber, d 0 x hat,
becomes d t x hat.
In other words, of course, this
here in red shown, is the
configuration at time t.
Now, notice that these fibers
here have particular
coordinates, 0 x 1, 0 x 2.
You can think of these
coordinates to be at the
beginning of that fiber.
Of course, these are
differential fibers.
They are very, very small.
These coordinates move
over to t x 1, t x 2.
In other words, the particle
from here moves to here and
takes on these coordinates.
We also, say, know,
that the whole--
I mean we also know, the whole
deformation field.
And therefore we can directly
calculate the deformation
gradient, the way I explained
it, by taking the
differentiation of the current
coordinates with respect to
the original coordinates.
And those differentiations
give us these elements.
If we do so, we have the
relationships between the d 0
x and d t x given
right down here.
Notice, d 0 x has these
components in the x 1 x 2
coordinate frame.
And you can see, for example,
this 0.866, the component in
the x 1 direction, this
0.5 is the component
into the x 2 direction.
If we multiply this
out, we get d t x.
And d t x, shown here, has
no component into the x 2
direction, but has a component
of 0.75 long
into the x 1 direction.
What this tells us, is that if
we know the motion of the body
from time 0 to time t, and
particularly at time t, and if
we have calculated the
deformation gradient the way
we have defined it, then we can
relate how the original
fibers, or the fibers in the
original configuration will
rotate and stretch.
And that relationship is given
via the deformation gradient,
as surely shown here
quite physically.
Because this fiber, originally
here, has rotated into a new
position, and has, in this
particular case, been
compressed.
So, this relationship tells us
how the fiber has moved,
rotated, and compressed.
It does not tell us how
much the movement was.
That is not given by
this relationship.
That we have already, because
we have to have that
information to calculate
t 0 x.
But what this information, this
equation gives us, is how
much the fiber has rotated and
compressed, or stretched.
Well, let's look at another
fiber, the one that we had on
the earlier viewgraph.
Here, another fiber.
And if we recognize, of course,
that for that material
particle here, the same material
particle still, we
still have the same deformation
gradient.
We can take this fiber, or
rather the vectorial
representation of that fiber,
as given here, multiply this
out, and we directly find out
what has happened to that
infinitesimal fiber in the
motion that we're considering.
Notice, in this particular case,
the components of this
fiber are 0 in this direction,
1.5 into that direction.
And it has moved to here, and
has taken on components 1 and
1 into each of the coordinate
directions.
The deformation gradient is
very useful for various
measures, computations
that we perform in
finite element analysis.
And one such computation
is to calculate the
mass density ratios.
In other words, we have to
assess how the mass density of
the body, as it moves through
the space, changes.
Let us look at how we do that.
Here we have our stationary
coordinate
system, x 1, x 2, x 3.
And in that stationary
coordinate system, I'd like to
focus our attention onto a
differential volume, a very
small volume.
I call that 0 d V curl.
A curl is there because it is a
specific volume that we now
want to look at.
Notice that the volume that
I'm talking about here is
spanned out by the
differential.
Differential is d 0 x curl
1, 2 and 3 not shown.
But this is the infinitesimal
volume at time 0.
Now, in the motion from time
0 to time t, of course this
volume will change.
And at time t, it
looks like this.
Notice that these
differentials here have changed.
We show just one, d 0 x curl
one, has gone over into d t x
curl 1, the t now
denoting time t.
And this is the volume obtained
from, that can be
calculated from these
vectors shown here.
In fact, this is how we
calculate this volume, and can
therefore relate, also,
the mass densities.
Let us look at some of
the basic equations.
First of all, we can say that
the mass in this volume, this
differential volume that we have
focused our attention on,
and that I have given a curl
for that reason, that that
mass must be preserved.
And this means that this
relationship must hold.
Volume times mass density at
time t must be equal to volume
times mass density at time 0.
We can show, then, that this
relationship holds.
And I will talk about that just
now it a little bit more.
And these two relationships,
then, clearly give us that
this is how the mass
density changes.
In other words, the mass density
at time t can directly
be calculated from the mass
density at time 0 and the
determinant of the deformation
gradient tensor.
Notice, in three dimensional
analysis, this is a three by
three matrix.
And you would have to calculate
this matrix, at the
particular point that you're
focusing your attention on,
and take the determinant
of that matrix.
Let us look at this relationship
here, because
that is a very basic
relationship.
It tells how the volume, the
differential volumes change as
a function of time.
And to show you how we arrive
at this relationship, I've
just compiled here a
few viewgraphs to
give you the proof.
Initially, we can say that d 0
x curl 1 is given via this
relationship.
Notice, this is the length
of this vector, simply.
And, notice that I had aligned
this vector with the x 1
coordinate axis, therefore
these 0s.
Similar, d 0 x curl 2 was
aligned with the x 2
coordinate axis, and therefore
these two 0s.
And the length of the
vector is d s 2.
d x curl 3 is given similarly,
but aligned, this vector is
aligned in the 3 direction, and
the length was given as,
is given as d s 3.
Hence, by simple calculation,
of course, we find directly
that the volume, the
differential volume that in
the original configuration, is
given via this equation.
But, if we now recognize that
we can express d t x curl i
via this relationship here, and
that is nothing else than
applying the deformation
gradient tensor the way we
already talked about.
We looked already at examples
where we put in a particular
fiber, original configuration,
and calculated how this fiber
stretched, deformed from
time 0 to time t.
I just gave you some examples.
And we use that information now,
here, to express the d t
x curl i in terms
of d 0 x curl i.
Of course, for i
equals 1, 2, 3.
And now we use here a formula
that you must have encountered
some time ago, in your studies
of mathematics.
If you look at your old math
books, I'm sure you can
extract that formula, which
simply says that the volume
given, spanned by these vectors,
is given via this
product here, as a cross product
of these two vectors,
and the dot product of the
resulting two vectors.
This, of course, gives you a
vector here, and you dot this
vector with this vector, and you
get, directly, a number,
which is the volume
of interest.
However, if we now multiply
this out here, you find,
directly, that this
is the answer.
In other words, the deformation
gradient comes in
right there.
The determinant of
the deformation
gradient comes in here.
Of course, it comes in here
because you would substitute
from here into there.
And once again, since this
product here is nothing else
than the original volume,
we're home.
We have proven that d t V curl
is equal to the determinant of
t 0 x times 0 d V curl, the
determinate of the deformation
gradient in this relationship
between the
differential volumes.
It's really an interesting
proof, and maybe you want to
think a little bit more about
it, and even go through this
arithmetic here, to really
reinforce the understanding of
what we are doing here.
Let's look at a simple example
to just exemplify once again
what we just talked about.
Here we have a little example.
A piece of material 1 long,
that in its original
configuration is 1 long,
I should say.
We are stretching that
piece of material up
to time t, as shown.
We assume uniform stretching.
We assume plain strain
conditions.
In other words, the strain
through the thickness is equal
to 0 here, in this
particular case.
And the deformation field is
assumed to be as shown here.
Then, with the deformation field
given, clearly we can
calculate this deformation
gradient.
Here, this component is simply
obtained by differentiating t
x 1 with respect to 0 x 1.
If you do so, you get a 1 here
plus 0.25, giving you a 1.25.
Because there is no shearing
in the material, and no
rotation, these off diagonal
terms are 0.
And, because there is no
stretching through this
direction, and through the
thickness direction, we have
1s right there.
To take the determinant of this
matrix is rather simple.
You just take the product of
the diagonal terms, and you
directly obtain 1.25 for
its determinant.
Now, let us plug this
into our formula.
And here we have the result
of that formula.
It tells us 0 rho is equal to
1.25 t rho for any particle,
right here, because this
relationship is independent of
the 0 x 1 component.
Well, of course, this is also
a result of the uniform
stretching.
Notice that this makes
physical sense.
If we have taken a piece
of material up here--
once more let us look at it--
that does not shrink here,
that does not stretch or
shrink in this normal direction
as well, then surely
the mass density has to decrease
as we stretch it.
And in fact, this is being shown
right down here, t rho
is equal to 0 rho
divided by 1.25.
So, the result makes sense.
We use also the inverse
deformation gradient.
And here, on this viewgraph,
I've just summarized a few
equations regarding this inverse
deformation gradient.
Here, we now look at the
equation, where on the
left-hand side we have the
material fiber at time 0, and
on the right-hand side is the
material fiber at time t.
In other words, d 0 x on the
left-hand side, and d t x on
the right-hand side.
The inverse deformation gradient
stands right here.
Mathematically, we can show that
the inverse deformation
gradient is nothing else
than t 0 x inverse.
Of course, notice that 0 t
x would be calculated by
differentiating the original
coordinates with respect to
the coordinates at time t.
However, we can also calculate
this matrix directly by taking
this matrix here, where we
differentiate the coordinates
at time t with respect to the
original coordinates.
And then, having obtained this
matrix, calculated this
matrix, we simply invert it.
Well the proof that indeed
holds is given
down here in green.
We simply take the top equation
and substitute for d
t x, as shown here, our
relationship that we had
already earlier.
And, if we then, well, look at
this equation, we can put
brackets around here.
And since d 0 x is equal to d
0 x for any material fiber,
this must be the identity
matrix, which already
completes the proof.
An important theorem in
continuum mechanics is the
polar decomposition theorem,
which tells that the
deformation gradient, t 0 x, can
always be decomposed into
a rotation matrix and
a stretch matrix.
The rotation matrix is an
orthogonal matrix, of course,
meaning that R, transposed R,
is the identity matrix.
And the stretch matrix is
a symmetric matrix.
This can always be
done for any x.
And the proof, actually, is
given in the textbook.
Please look at your study guide,
where I indicate where
you can find the proof
in the textbook.
And it might be quite good to
actually go through that proof
in some detail, so as to
reinforce your understanding
of what this theorem
really tells.
The important point, once again,
is that we can always
write the x matrix into this
form as R times u.
And to give you an example of
what this means, let's look at
this one here.
Here we have, in the coordinate
frame x 1 x 2, a
piece of material
3 long 2 wide.
This is the original
configuration of the material.
And that material moves
from time 0 to
time t, as shown here.
First it moves, it is being
stretched into the x 1
direction and into the x 2
direction to take on the
configuration shown in red.
And then it rotates to take on
the configuration in green.
And that, indeed, is the
configuration at time t.
Let us calculate the x matrix
corresponding to that
configuration, and see how
it would be decomposed
into R times u.
Well, we have done
that down here.
Notice, this is the
x matrix, t 0 x.
These are the components
of that matrix.
And here we have the R matrix,
t 0 R. And here we
have the t 0 u.
In other words, this is the
rotation matrix, and this is
the stretch matrix.
Notice this stretch matrix
is indeed symmetric.
Let's look at the components in
the stretch matrix a little
bit closer.
1.33 is nothing else than 4
divided by 3, in other words,
the stretching into
the x 1 direction.
1.5, down here, is nothing else
than the stretching into
x 2 direction, namely
2 goes over into 3.
3 divided by 2, 1.5.
Notice that these off diagonal
elements are 0, the reason
being that there has been no
shearing from the original
configuration to the
red configuration.
The rotation matrix really
expresses mathematically the
movement of this red piece of
material into the green
configuration.
Notice that the entries in
this rotation matrix are
nothing else than cosines
and sines of
this 30-degree rotation.
For example, here you have
the cosine of 30 degrees.
This is the sine
of 30 degrees.
In fact, it's the rotation of
this material fiber right
there, from here into there.
Well, this is the rotation
matrix and stretch matrix for
this example.
And we could easily construct
other examples.
In fact, you find in the
textbook some more examples
that you might want to study
regarding this particular
phenomenon.
Using the deformation gradient,
we can describe, we
can define a Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor.
There is a right Cauchy-Green
There is also a left
Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor which, however,
we will not be using.
So, when I talk about the
Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor, I really mean the right
Cauchy-Green deformation tensor.
And it's defined
as shown here.
We take the deformation
gradient, transposed, times
the deformation gradient.
Now, notice the deformation
gradient is always a three by
three matrix, in a three
dimensional coordinate space.
However, it can be
a non-symmetric
or symmetric matrix.
Generally, it is a non-symmetric
matrix.
It would be a symmetric matrix
if there has been no rotation
points on it.
But, in general, it's
non-symmetric.
Notice that this non-symmetric
matrix, multiplied here, as
shown by the non-symmetric
matrix transposed, makes c
symmetric, a very important
information.
Well, indeed, if we substitute
for x here, we find that c is
nothing else than
t 0 u squared.
In other words, the stretch
matrix squared, since R is
orthogonal.
R goes in here.
But R transposed R, of course,
is the identity matrix.
And therefore c is
simply u squared.
Notice that t 0 c is independent
of the rotation,
via this equation here, and
therefore we say that c is
invariant under a rigid
body rotation.
In other words, a rigid body
rotation of a material fiber
does not enter into
the elements of c.
Let's look at an example.
Two dimensional motion, the
original configuration for the
piece of material that I like
to consider is shown here.
It moves from time 0 to time t,
to the red configuration.
And then, in the increment of
time delta t to that green
configuration.
But this movement over time
delta t is simply a rigid body
motion of 90 degrees.
Well, we can calculate t 0
x corresponding to this
configuration.
Here it's done.
And, by the formula that I gave
you, you get directly t 0
c by taking x transposed
times x.
You get this matrix here.
Well, now we can also
calculate t 0 x.
How do we obtain, by the
way, this matrix?
There is a subtle point.
You obtain this matrix simply by
pre-multiplying this matrix
by a rotation matrix
corresponding to this
90-degree rotation.
This is the answer.
And if we now take this matrix,
transposed by the
matrix itself, in other words
this product x transpose x, we
get the c matrix.
And we notice that the c
matrices are the same for both
of these configurations.
In other words, this simply
exemplifies that the rigid
body rotation from red to green
here did not enter into
the elements of the c.
They did not change from time
t to time t plus delta t.
We use this c matrix to define
a strain measure, the
Green-Lagrange strain measure.
It's, of course, a strain
measure that is very well
known, described in many,
many textbooks.
And it is, however, very useful
for finite element
analysis, as I briefly pointed
out already earlier.
This is the definition of the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor.
Notice, this here is a three
by three matrix.
And we are taking this three
We subtract the identity
matrix.
The identity matrix, of course,
being just 1s on the
diagonal, and 0s on all the
off diagonal elements.
And there is a 1/2 here that
gives us the definition of the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor.
There are a number of very
interesting properties that
this strain tensor displays.
And I've listed them here.
We can see that this strain
tensor is symmetric.
tensor does not change from
time t to time t plus delta t if
the only motion from time t
to time t plus delta t was
a rigid body motion.
And we can see directly that
the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor is 0 if, from time 0 to
time t, the only motion was a
rigid body motion.
One can prove these particular
items, these statements, and I
would like to encourage
you to do so.
While you are doing it, I
will do the same here.
And then we share our
experiences regarding these
proofs just afterwards.
Well, here I am giving now to
you some information regarding
these proofs.
t 0 epsilon is symmetric because
t 0 c is symmetric.
And remember, we take here a
symmetric matrix from which we
subtract a symmetric matrix, and
clearly, the result must
be a symmetric matrix.
A very simple proof really.
Regarding the second item that I
mentioned earlier, for rigid
body motion, we know that from
time t to time t plus delta t,
we have that x at time t plus
delta t can be written as R
times t 0 x.
In other words, here I'm talking
about the deformation
gradient at time t plus delta
t, and here about the
deformation gradient
at time t.
And they are related merely
by a rotation matrix.
Now, if you substitute from here
into this equation, but
apply the time t plus delta t,
you obtain, of course, as we
saw actually on the earlier
example, that this c matrix
does not change.
And therefore, also the
Green-Lagrange stain tensor
does not change.
In fact, all of this information
was really
addressed in the earlier
examples that we discussed.
Also, for rigid body motion, we
have that the c matrix is
simply the identity matrix,
because remember, the c
matrix, Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor, does not
change with rigid
body rotation.
It is equal to the
identity matrix.
And if you then takes this c
matrix and substitute right up
there, on the top, you get that
the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor is 0.
So, 3 properties, really, that
we want to keep in mind
regarding the Green-Lagrange
strain tensor when we
later on use it.
Another definition of the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor
is given on this viewgraph.
In fact, this right-hand side
that I'm showing here is
simply obtained by substituting,
for the
deformation gradient, the
identity matrix plus the
deformation while the
displacement derivatives, with
respect to the coordinates.
In other words, what you want
to do, basically, is to
substitute for t 0 x, in
terms of displacements.
And if you go through and write
all the information out,
you end up that the t 0 epsilon
i j component of the
Green-Lagrange strain
tensor is given by
this equation here.
Notice that we have here i, j,
the same subscript that you
see here, too.
Of course, we're differentiating
with respect
to the j component here.
Here we have j, i, and
here k, i k,j.
We're summing over k here.
Notice also, that this part
here is non-linear in the
displacements.
This part is non-linear in the
displacements because these
are, so to say, quadratic
terms.
This here, this part, is linear
in displacements.
From time to time, students
approach me and say to me,
well, you must have neglected
something in the definition,
or in this Green-Lagrange
strain tensor.
Because you're only going
up to quadratic terms.
you must have neglected cubic
terms, and high order terms.
Well, the answer there is, we
have really neglected nothing.
The point is, that we have
defined this tensor to be
given by this equation.
Of course, my earlier definition
was in terms of
deformation gradients,
in terms of
the deformation gradient.
Now we actually have here
substituted displacements.
But it's still a definition.
This is, in fact,
the same tensor.
The same components here would
be calculated using the
earlier definition than
this one here.
Same thing.
And, as I say, it holds for any
deformation, any amount of
straining and stretching.
Let's look at one example, a
very simple example, where we
have a simple four-node
element that
we are pulling out.
Originally, it it is in the
black configuration.
It goes over into the
red configuration.
If we calculate t 0 epsilon 1 1
from the formula that I just
showed you, you get
these two terms.
This here is the engineering
strain term that we are very
well familiar with.
And this is here the non-linear
term, because it's
a quadratic term.
Non-linear in the displacement,
of course.
If we plot this information,
as shown here on the graph,
notice we're showing here t
delta over L, the original
length, where t delta
is the displacement.
And we have plotting here the
epsilon 1 1 component.
Actually, we should
have said here--
let me make this correction
right now here--
we should have had, really
have had here a
t 0 epsilon 1 1.
The t 0 was missing there.
Well, if we plot, in other
words, this component here as
a function of these elements
here, of the t delta over 0 L,
we get this red line,
the red line.
Notice the non-linearality
in that strain.
The engineering strain, which
is only the first term here,
gives us a straight line.
Notice that this strain here
increases quite rapidly as you
pull out, and it decreases in
magnitude here, with this
curvature, as you push in.
So there's no symmetry in the
strain when you extend or
compress a piece of material.
In the engineering strain
component, of course, we see a
symmetry, because we have
a straight line.
Let us look at another example
to calculate once the
Green-Lagrange strain.
Here, we have the original
configuration
of a four-node element.
And that four-node element,
shown black here, goes over
into this configuration at time
t, stretched into two
directions, and then, at time t
plus delta t, it has rotated
by 45 degrees.
The deformation gradient
corresponding to time t is
shown here.
The Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor shown here.
Notice no off diagonal
elements.
Because the piece of material,
the four-node element-- you
may think of this as a four-node
element, of course--
has simply been stretched
and compressed.
There's no shearing.
Therefore, we have
0 terms here.
And, if we calculate the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor,
we get this answer.
Once again, no shearing
components in
this tensor as well.
If we now do the same for the
configuration at time t plus
delta t, the green
configuration, we obtain this
deformation gradient, this
Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor, and this is a
Green-Lagrange strain tensor.
Where we notice that the
Cauchy-Green deformation
tensor has not changed, and
the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor has also not changed.
And this is what, of course,
we have proven already
earlier, that from time t to
time t plus delta t, the
Green-Lagrange strain tensor
and the Cauchy-Green
deformation tensor, both
of those do not change.
However for rigid body motion,
the x tensor, the deformation
gradient, does change, look at
here, because this deformation
gradient is affected
by the rotation.
Let's look at another example,
because all these examples
really enrich our understanding
of what these
kinematic quantities stand for,
and what they give us.
Here, we look at the example of
a simple shear deformation.
Originally, the element that we
are looking at was in this
configuration.
And, it is sheared over.
You can think of this top line
being simply moved over
horizontally into the
red configuration.
Notice that the original
length here is 1.
This length is also 1.
Notice that the movement
over is t delta.
And we calculate
the deformation
gradient once again.
The deformation gradient now
being given by via these
components.
Let's try to explain these
components a bit.
Well, this here is really the
differentiation of t x 1 with
respect to 0 x 1.
Now, t x 1 has not changed,
and therefore, this is 1.
t x 1 is equal to 0 x 1
in other words, and
therefore, this is 1.
Notice that the same holds also
for partial t x 2 with
respect to 0 x 2.
Notice that this element here
stands for partial t x 1 with
respect to 0 x 2.
And there, we look at partial
t x 1, a change into this
direction as we walk that
direction, and that gives us
this t delta, t delta over
this length here.
In other words, this element
is nothing else than this
length divided by that length.
And it's, of course, the same
for any material particle over
this domain.
Because all of these material
particles have
been sheared over.
Well, if you now take x
transposed times x, you get
this matrix here.
And you identify directly
these terms, if we then
calculate by the formula given,
the Green-Lagrange
strain, this is the result.
Notice that here we have now
shearing components.
And notice also one very
interesting phenomena, a
component appearing here.
This is an interesting
component, because it is
really an enormous strain
component in this direction.
And now there's an epsilon 1, 1,
epsilon 2, 2, I should have
said, component, an epsilon 2,
2 component that is non-zero
in this particular case,
In a material non-linear-only
formulation, where we only
include infinitesimal
displacements, in other words,
this part, of course,
would be 0.
And that is also signified
by the square term.
In other words, if indeed the
motion is small in this
direction, then this would
become 0, at least
approximately 0 when compared
to these terms, and it means
that the Green-Lagrange strain
tensor reduces to the
infinitesimal strain tensor that
we are so familiar with.
The 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff stress
tensor and the Green-Lagrange
strain tensors are energetically
conjugate.
This is a very important
statement.
And this is the reason why we
are working with these two
tensors, the 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor
and the Green-Lagrange
strain tensor.
In fact, what is happening here,
is that this product
here, which is the virtual work
at time t per current
volume, per unit current volume,
that this here is
given, of course, by the Cauchy
stress times the small,
or the virtual, infinitesimal
strain, is defined this way.
And here, we have the virtual
work at time t per unit
original volume.
And that is given by the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress times
the variation in the
Green-Lagrange strain.
We already had, earlier, that
the integration of this over
the current volume is equal
to the integration of this
quantity over the
original volume.
Well, this is here once more,
something to be kept in mind.
But the important point is that
the energy, that these
two quantities are energetically
conjugate, and
this is expressed via
this product here.
Let's look at the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor now.
The 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff stress
tensor in indicial notation is
defined as shown here.
And we had already that
definition early on a viewgraph.
In matrix notation, we can
directly say this is the way
you can also write it.
Notice that the entries in this
three by three matrix--
I'm always thinking about three
components, or rather,
three dimensional coordinate
space--
the entries here are nothing
else than those elements.
The entries of this matrix,
of course, are
those elements here.
And similarly here, this is
the scalar that we talked
about earlier already.
If we solve from here for Cauchy
stresses, we directly
obtain these two equations.
Notice that in this matrix
notation now, we have the
deformation gradient.
Whereas in the earlier equation
that we looked at
here, we had the inverse
deformation gradient.
Well, these are relations that
we want to keep in mind, and
that we will be referring to
quiet abundantly later on.
Let us look at some properties
of the 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor.
First of all, t 0
s is symmetric.
While that can be seen directly
by looking at the
definition, you might want to
prove it to yourself with a
small example as well.
t 0 s is invariant under
a rigid body motion,
translation, and/or rotation.
Hence, t 0 s only
changes when the
material is actually deformed.
This is a very important
statement, important fact, I
should say, and we want to look
at an example just now.
t 0 s has no direct physical
interpretation.
Well, if you look at some
books, you'll see some
pictures regarding t 0 s,
sorry, regarding the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
In fact, I have some pictures
in my book,
in an example there.
But, these pictures are quite
far fetched, and they really
don't give as deep a physical
insight as one would like to
have with a stress measure.
I personally like to now take
almost the attitude of saying,
well, I accept that there is
no real strong physical
interpretation of this
stress measure.
It is used because it's
a convenient stress
measure to deal with.
We would not, in an engineering
analysis, really
print it out in a computer
program.
As I said earlier, we would,
of course, want to have the
Cauchy stress as the stress
measure with which we want to
design our structure.
I look at it as a measure that
is convenient to work with in
the engineering analysis.
It's interesting, of course,
from a theoretical point of
view to look at the elements and
to see how large they are,
how small they are, when
compared to the Cauchy stress,
the real physical stress that
we're interested in.
But, we don't really need to
look for a strong physical
interpretation.
I know we are engineers.
Engineers like to see pictures,
like to understand
physically what's happening.
And I can assure you that I've
tried myself quite hard to get
physical interpretation of this
definition, of this 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
But, I have not arrived with
many good results.
The best I could do is given
in my textbook, in the book
that you are using
as a textbook.
Let's look at an example here.
The example of a four-node
element being stretched and
rotated as shown here, and then
rotated as shown here.
Notice that from time t, shown
as the red configuration, to
time t plus delta t, we have
only a rigid body motion, a
rotation of 60 degrees.
Of course, the material would
be subjected to some Cauchy
stresses, and Cauchy stresses
in this configuration and
Cauchy stresses in this
configuration.
Let us see how the Cauchy
stresses, and how the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stresses evolve
during this motion.
And on this viewgraph here,
we have summarized that
information.
At time t the deformation
gradient is as shown here.
The Cauchy stresses,
say, are like this.
Of course, we would have to
introduce the material law, et
cetera, et cetera.
Let us assume that the Cauchy
stresses are like that.
And then, given the Cauchy
stresses, the deformation
gradient, we calculate the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor.
Let's say that this is now,
has now been calculated.
And we do the same at
time t plus delta t.
We know that there has, of
course, been additional motion
from time t to time t plus
delta t, which means that
these elements here
will change.
And you should now be in a
position to calculate this
tensor, because you know there
is only a rigid body motion
that is being applied.
And then, knowing this tensor,
we can directly also calculate
the 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff
stress tensor.
And we can calculate the
Cauchy stress tensor.
So we can really calculate
all of these.
And what do we see?
This is the really
important point.
We see that the 2nd
Piola-Kirchhoff stress tensor
has not changed from time t
to time t plus delta t.
This is the important
information
that I mentioned earlier.
However, the Cauchy
stress tensor,
of course, has changed.
The Cauchy stress tensor
has changed.
One can, of course, prove that
the 2nd Piola-Kirchhoff stress
tensor does not change when the
material is only subjected
to a rigid body motion.
And such proof is actually
given in the textbook.
But this is a simple
application, and it
exemplifies to you what I
mean by that statement.
It's an important statement that
you should keep in mind
as we go along with our further
discussion of the
mathematical basis
of non-linear
finite element analysis.
This brings us then to the
end of this lecture.
I have tried to give you some
of the mathematical bases,
some of the ingredients, rather,
that we are using in
finite element analysis.
We have discussed stress and
strain measures that we will
be encountering further
in the next lectures.
Thank you very much for
your attention.